what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so we are finally getting back into
fear itself and we're really covering in
this part like the one tie-in that
everybody carried out really I always
say the one part of the story that most
people care about which is the uncanny
x-men tie an unstoppable juggernaut so
it's kind of funny in these crossover
events that Marvel will do they'll just
be segments or people are just like so I
don't care about anything else that
happens but I care about like that one
thing because it's cool like like this
okay at the end of the day that's really
all how much boil down to just the cool
moments like that's really it like I
could cover the entirety of like Chris
Klarman
a Chris Claremont x-men run but there's
only like a handful of super cool things
that anybody would really care about so
like it's one of those interesting
things and like color book events and
all that kind of good stuff but any
event switching over to the x-men this
is all post utopia now for those of you
guys who are familiar with this bear
with me while I went over this for the
guys who were not uh utopia in the x-men
landscape was basically after the events
of decimation right like The Scarlet
Witch took away 98% of the mutant powers
population and then you had an event
called Dark Reign so so you had like
Secret Invasion where the scrolls
basically invade the entirety of Earth
in the Marvel Universe they start
replacing superheroes and so what ended
up happening is Deadpool and actually
send information to the superheroes on
how to defeat the scrolls and then
Norman Osborn
intercepted the information and then
used it to win and so yeah and so that
goes into Tony Stark being removed as
director of shield Norman Osborn becomes
the new director he disband shield
crates hammer and then he starts Dark
Reign and so in order like consolidate
his power he basically started trying to
get rid of like all these different
groups but then you have like the x-men
and at the time the x-men were still
living in Westchester I'm pretty sure
and they were recovering from the events
of decimation but realizing that Norman
Osborn would seize the opportunity to
basically ask them what they did is they
left the United States proper that is to
say the continental United States and
they took up residence on an island off
the coast of San Francisco so
technically speaking they were outside
of the US government's jurisdiction but
not really and they were still
considered to be part of San Francisco
now the way that this happened was
actually by way of this chick Sadie
Sinclair she's basically the one who
invited the x-men de to stay in Utopia
in San Francisco it was kind of like a
friend for the x-men but not really she
appeared in like 15 issues so she never
really had like any meaningful role but
with the x-men residing in San Francisco
and being on good terms with Sadie
Sinclair they basically briefed her on
what's going on so far and what
the things that's really pointed out
here and this is pretty important is
this established that juggernaut is
insanely powerful at this point multiple
times over than how he normally is
because Winnie has the Crimson gem of
cyttorak as we know the inscription goes
you know whosoever touches this jammer
for this is this Jim shall possess the
bands of the power of the crimson bands
of cyttorak henceforth you who reads
these words shall go forward forevermore
a human juggernaut paraphrasing ah when
it comes to to that level of power he's
already unstoppable in his own right is
one of those things were like once the
juggernaut starts and starts moving
nobody can really stop him and he's
invulnerable to pretty much every form
of physical harm the only way to really
defeat him is to remove his helmet and
then use a psychic attack or something
along those lines because even with his
helmet gone conventional weapons too
wouldn't work he'd be bulletproof they
were just bounced off it and so when it
comes to something like this what this
does is it amplifies his power even that
much more and so it's basically the
power of the juggernaut with Asgardian
tech and it's insane what he's capable
of not only that he's basically amassed
a whole bunch of followers and this has
really done more for like a ransom tag
in the sense that earlier what it would
has essentially gone on or at least what
happens here is that when the x-men
launched the initial attack it's really
more of like testing to see what they
can and can't do because they don't
really know what kind of power the
juggernaut has since it's been amplified
and so what Cyclops and company show up
it's the testing ground they grab
Colossus they grab Kitty Pryde they go
through and they say okay look like
we've got to find a way to defeat this
guy and it kind of works for what it is
but initially this this initial skirmish
is disastrous because like all the x-men
are absolutely right I mean they're
there decimated Cyclops is manhandled
with no real effort on behalf of
juggernaut Iceman is taken out in the
blink of an eye and these are some Omega
level characters and so with none of
them really being able to stand alone
against against juggernaut Cyclops
essentially calls in and says okay look
we have more that we have to do here so
this of course leads to the arrival of
Magneto and it's one of the cool things
because you would expect Magneto to be
able to slow down juggernaut or
something along those lines but after
all he is wearing metal so why not just
lift him into the air but with the
enhancements offered by the serpent this
basically makes juggernaut and his
weapons immune to the powers of magneto
and so where magneto stands up and and
essentially tries to like the oh
bloggers I guess catch the hammer of
juggernaut when he throws it it just
keeps moving towards him ultimately a
case it takes Kitty Pryde coming in the
way Phase II Magneto
so that is the hammer of hash right
through him otherwise it would have
killed and this big
basically means that like there's no
real way for the x-men to stop him that
juggernaut truly is unstoppable at this
moment in time and so what they do is
they basically say we need Hope Summers
now calling Hope Summers in is no small
thing but you're talking about a
character who has the ability to
duplicate the powers of anybody around
her with no upper limit and that's what
she does she literally goes through and
starts tapping in to the powers so she's
basically a mutant with the powers of a
thousand x-men or I guess really like a
you know a couple hundred x-men who in
turn is facing off against juggernaut
and noticed this she does it by the skin
of her teeth what she ends up doing is
seizing control of his helmet and then
basically melting his helmet and pulling
it off and that's all she can do because
the sheer number of powers she's
absorbed has been entirely overwhelming
now what this does is it allows Emma
Frost to basically use cerebro cerebro
and then tap into the mind of juggernaut
and notice this this is one of the funny
things Emma Frost is very Cavalier in
how she does this right she's like okay
you know his helmets gone whatever you
know I'll just use my my telepathy
that's you know amplified several times
over and then just you know shut his
mind down or something along those lines
it doesn't work not by a longshot her
psychic mind is effectively like
fractured and and destroyed but is it's
to the point where she's actually thrown
temporarily into a catatonic state
because she cannot begin to understand
the sheer amount of energy like psychic
energy rage fear anger the whole nine
yards that juggernaut the juggernauts
putting off at the moment it's way more
than she knows how to handle and the
juggernaut moves forward and so at this
point it's a matter of kind of running a
conflict on two fronts for Cyclops again
as leader of the team one part is
getting information seeing if there's a
way to defeat him and the other part is
basically creating a stopgap measure and
so what they end up doing is they end up
traveling to meet Illyana Rasputin now
Illyana Rasputin is currently locked up
in the inner brick inside the I guess
the ex brick is what it's called and the
reason for this is because shortly
before this story there was essentially
the return of Legion and the reason why
the return of Legion has happened is
because it was basically the purgatory
was a project purgatory saga and it was
this idea that after the events of
Inferno which is a way old sword that
took place in the 1980s when Jean Grey's
clone Madeline prior had launched an
attack on New York by unleashing demons
from this you know from basically like
the netherworld another realm basically
where Illyana Rasputin draws her powers
what project her tits were ended up
doing was realizing this was a power
source and so what they started engaging
in
was what hit what amounted to like gene
splicing splicing the genes of mutants
with like demons and then kind of trying
to create their own army of sorts but
what happened was Illyana Rasputin had
realized what was going on in the power
that was available there and essentially
brought Legion in from a different
dimension and basically brought him back
to life but because Legion is so
mentally unstable because he's so insane
he's a credible threat to everyone that
like his powers to warp reality or
extreme so with this kind of a thing in
mind Illyana Rasputin was basically
considered by Cyclops to be a credible
threat to the mutant community so she
was thrown in the brig and so seeking
out this information and asking her
questions she basically says look I can
study this and I could take you to where
you need to go but you're gonna have to
let me out of the cell in order to do it
so it's a dangerous game that's being
played something else is going on here
what we end up doing it's kind of
sidetracking for a second and picking up
with some of these forces who are trying
to stop jabber not and none of it's
working you know like you have you have
pixie who's creating like portals trying
to get him to different locations and he
just walks right through as if they're
not there
you've got rogue who tried to like
absorb the power of the juggernaut way
more than she could handle and she ended
up shutting down no one can stop him
and so what ends up happening is they
end up taking Illyana Rasputin basically
out into the middle of nowhere she
creates a portal and transports
everybody with Cyclops to the realm of
cyttorak now this is where things really
get cool so CID Iraq is one of the elder
demons that existed in the Marvel
Universe way way back in the day and was
wolf was one of the people who retreated
he's also a part of the octet since the
octet this was a group of super old ant
--'tis that existed in on earth and the
Marvel in the Marvel Universe and the
idea was they had a contest over which
one was the most powerful and so what
they ended up doing is because they
couldn't really enter the main Marvel
Universe dimension what they ended up
doing was basically creating artifacts
one for each one of these members of the
octet Sion's and they were placed around
earth but the idea was that an
individual would pick up one of these
artifacts and when they did they would
set the AA to set the octet since
prophecy in motion the earth would be
divided into eighths like an you know an
eighth of the Earth's population would
be an army for each one of these of
these beings and then in turn it would
just be like a massive war and in time
kind of conflict and whichever army
proved to be victorious would show which
member of the octet sense was the most
powerful and so during the Korean War
Cain Marko picked up the artifact that
belonged to sit Iraq which of course was
the crimson gem not with with Ileana
showing up here she plays it exceedingly
smart what she'd basically tell Sid Iraq
is juggernaut is using power that is
somebody else's now what
comes to sit Iraq he's very much like
the Old Testament God of Abraham right
like I am a selfish god and so do not
use anybody's power before me and that's
how sit iraq functions that's what he is
because the role that juggernaut is
playing is to serve explicitly for the
avatar of Sid Iraq the avatar of
destruction and so learning juggernaut
has accepted the power of another entity
out there basically means a SID Iraq
strips juggernaut of all of his power
basically takes away everything the
sitter I could Gabe had given him now it
does not really mean that juggernaut is
now insanely weak hopelessly on cable
you know incapable of defeating anybody
he's still insanely powerful but the
problem with this is an avatar has to
exist someone has to be the new
juggernaut and so we're Ileana Rasputin
initially steps up what is up happening
is Colossus takes her place and says no
I will be the new host for for the
Crimson gymnast in Iraq now this is
where things get kind of crazy too this
is something else that happens
transitioning back to the forces of the
x-men there's two major things that
happened the first is that gambit tries
to use his powers to detonate objects by
literally take it like touching it to an
aircraft carrier that magneto is sending
like sending directly into juggernaut
and the idea is to bring the aircraft
carrier down onto him and then gambit
will blow it up it happens and it still
doesn't work I mean it's crazy like the
level of power that this guy has used up
he as hell but with with Colossus taking
on the new power of juggernaut it is
interesting because in the minds of
Kitty Pryde who's basically there she
essentially says like this will kill
Colossus it'll it'll kill who he was and
transform him into somebody else and
that's kind of what happens here is that
when Colossus arrives onto the scene and
starts facing off against unstoppable
juggernaut one of the things he comments
on is it like he doesn't really want to
stop but he has a desire to just destroy
things as the avatar of cyttorak
you seek to destroy you seek to conquer
and to eliminate things and so what this
means for Colossus is that he's
following that exact Charter and so
showing up here and and facing off
against juggernaut one of the things he
says is that in this instance in this
conflict here that it's not really like
Colossus is winning easily that for
where Colossus is basically unstoppable
that with the power Ken Marcou still has
he's still faster he's still stronger
he's still more durable like he's he's
still he's still far more capable than
Colossus the difference here is that
Colossus is unstoppable that's the
difference that's the one
thing like Colossus literally just
starts tearing him limb from limb
because at this point it just becomes a
war of attrition that Colossus is just
like this constant force facing off
against juggernaut and eventually
juggernaut will wear out eventually
he'll get tired and he won't be able to
fight anymore
and that's exactly what takes place when
is it going on here is the serpent
realizes what's what's what's happening
at this moment the fact that juggernaut
is basically losing any response whisks
him away basically snatches him up and
sends him directly back over of reason
directly back to where the serpents at
leaving Colossus in its current form now
what this does is this goes forward into
the future of Marvel Comics and even
directly into like Avengers vs. x-men
with unstoppable Colossus it was an
attempt to to change his character up to
kind of boost his popularity temporarily
and it worked it was it was a talk of
the town like every dude every single
forum everywhere was like all the time
about like unstoppable Colossus could
unstoppable causas beat this guy can he
beat that guy can t do this can he do
that it just turned out it just turned
into like battle forms all the time like
battle threats everywhere you went so
it's kind of interesting because in this
moment what ends up happening is that
following the departure of juggernaut
this really leads to the x-men just kind
of going back to business as usual but
one of the things that happens here is
Cyclops pays a visit directly to Sadie
and essentially says look if things are
how they are
then what Sadie had intended to do is
that if juggernaut got close enough to
utopia that what she wanted to do is
kind of take out the entire mutant
population and juggernaut in one fell
swoop now it wasn't really from a place
of being vindictive it was a practical
approach but Cyclops learned this was
the case Cyclops learned that ultimately
she was going to destroy utopia and so
what he ends up doing is basically
having Hope Summers sit outside and in
turn like take away the ability for
Sadie to control her own body and says
look this is how things are we keep to
ourselves we keep our own thanks for
giving us a home but if you believe
you're gonna be able to walk over the
x-men that's not gonna happen
because we have x-men back there that
can turn your blood to mercury we have
x-men that can make you lose control of
your bodily functions like we will have
them screw up your mind turn you inside
out and make you live the most horrid
life you could ever imagine all the
while you don't realize you're just
sitting in your living room so either
you can play ball and you can let us be
or we will make you suffer the most
horrific experiences you could ever
imagine in your entire life and this is
this is again continuing the trend of
Cyclops falling down the path and
becoming somewhat of a darker God
becoming more extreme and becoming
something more akin to a
but with that being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end if you
are new here to come this explain make
sure you guys have the sub button to
become part of the rob4 if you guys
enjoy this video make sure you drop a
like and yeah I will catch you all later
peace
[Music]
[Music]